hey everyone let's talk about tonsil
stones so what are tonsil stones well
these are compacted masses that actually
form in the CPS and crevices of your
tonsils and they're actually quite
common many people don't even know that
they have them now what are tonsil
stones made out of well they are made
out of a combination of bacteria from
your mouth and broken down food that
you've ate that has calcified along with
other substances and these substances
over time get trapped in these CPS and
crevices and will slowly grow how do you
know if you have tonsil stones what are
the signs and symptoms well one of the
easiest ways to know is go in front of a
mirror open your mouth and shine a light
in your mouth flex your throat like
you're about to cough or gag and look at
your tonsils and what you're looking for
are these white yellowish spots within
the tonsil tissue now some subtle signs
and symptoms that you may have tonsil
stones include halosis which is a fancy
term for bad breath in addition you may
have a bad taste in your mouth all the
time it just feels like it's in the back
of your throat or when you go to swallow
it may feel like you have something
stuck in your throat and this is
particularly true if you have a large
tonsil Stone in addition you may have a
persistent cough that just doesn't go
away so sometimes whenever you cough
parts of that stone can actually break
off so whenever you cough you may feel
like something in your mouth and you go
to look and you see this white yellowish
substance now over time as I pointed out
earlier these Stones can grow which
leads to a complication of tonsil stones
usually they're harmless but if they do
become impacted within those tonsil CPS
it could lead to infection and some
signs of an infection could include that
you have a swollen lip node underneath
your chin in this area right here or you
could notice that back in your tonsil
area it's very red and swollen and it
hurts whenever you swallow a lot of
times it's localized to one side because
the tonsil stone is on that particular
side but sometimes you could have it on
both if you have infected tonsil stones
on both sides and sometimes this can
also progress to an ear a so what is the
treatment for tonsil stones well one of
the best treatments is through
prevention and one way you can prevent
tonsil stones is through good oral
hygiene by practicing good oral hygiene
you will limit the Mount of bacteria in
your mouth so you want to make sure that
you are brushing your teeth regularly
flossing and using mouthwash
another step you can take is limiting
foods that promote the formation of
those stones so you want to limit foods
like soda the carbonat drinks along with
dairy or calcium rich foods also
avoiding alcohol and smoking can help as
well and keeping your mouth as moist as
possible however let's say that you have
a tonsil stone in there you're beyond
the prevention part what can you do well
a lot of times it's generally best just
to leave the stone in there because many
times they will fall out on their own
through coughing or swallowing however
if you have a rather large stone that
just isn't coming out you want to
consult with your doctor to help you
decide on what measures you should take
in removing the stone now it is possible
in some situations that you can attempt
to remove the stone yourself and if you
choose to do this you want to follow
some of these basic tips the very first
thing you want to do is that you want to
wash your hand and you want to reduce
the amount of germs in your mouth and
you can do this through gargling before
you actually attempt to remove the stone
when you gargle you can use a solution
of peroxide again it's two parts water
one part peroxide so you're diluting the
peroxide gargle and then do not swallow
the peroxide but spit it out then take a
clean cotton swab as you can see here
and apply pressure to the side of the CP
where you seen the tonsil Stone whenever
you apply pressure it should pop out
just like this once the tonsil stone is
out be sure to spit it out and then
after this you'll want to Gar
again and this is a really important
step because you just went in there with
a cotton swab and you can potentially
cause micro tears in that soft delicate
tissue of your tonsils microt tears can
become infected and sores can develop
another way to remove or manage tonsil
stones is through the usage of a water
pick or water flosser that ejects water
and it could help hopefully remove the
tonsil Stone from your throat now let's
say that you have a reoccurring chronic
problem with these tonsil stones where
you're getting infections all the time
well you want to consult with your
doctor about potentially a tonsil ectomy
where they can remove your tonsils
however in many cases of tonsil stones
they can be managed with prevention and
just attempting to remove them yourself
okay so that wraps up this video on
tonsil stones and if you'd like to watch
some more videos you can access the link
in the YouTube description below